[موسيقى]
هناك العديد من الاشياء التي تحزر الناس
او تصيبهم بالاكتئاب من المستقبل
لكن اعتقد ان تحولنا الى حضاره مستعمره
للفضاء احد الاشياء المشوقه في شان
المستقبل
اعتقد ان الفضاء هو من الاشياء التي تلهم
معظم الناس وان سالت الناس عن الحدث
الاكثر الهاما في التاريخ فعل الارجح ان
يجيبوا بانه الهبوط على سطح القمر
حتى لو سالت الناس في اي مكان في رايه
طموح عبقري مثقف غريب الاطوار وشغوف اعتقد
ان كل وسائط النقل باستثناء الصواريخ
ستصبح معتمده كليا على طاقه الكهربائيه
سيصبح امتلاك سياره غير ذاتيه القياده في
المستقبل مثل امتلاك حصان حيث قد تمتلك
واحدا وتستخدمه لاسباب ترفيهيه لكن ليس
للاستخدام اليومي ايلون ماسك العقل
المبتكر
اولى شركه السيارات الكهربائيه في امريكا
واكبر مزود للالواح الشمسيه في البلاد
والان رائد الرحلات التجاريه الى الفضاء
انه العبقري الطموح الذكي والملياردير
الغريب الاطوار المهوس بالتكنولوجيا الذي
هز العالم باكمله بابتكارات غير مسبوقه
رجل ذو صيت دائع في مجال السفر الى الفضاء
والقطاع التكنولوجي
صاحب شخصيه قياديه جذابه ويحب فعل الخير
لايلون ماسك صفات عديده
انه تجسيد حقيقي للرجل الحديدي واليوم
لديه حلم
يعتبره العديدون غير قابل للتحقيق خلال
حياته على الاقل
[موسيقى]
اعلن انه سيكون سعيدا فقط عندما يصعد
البشر الى المريخ
ولكن حلمه هذا يقع ضمن مجموعه واسعه من
الاحلام الكبيره التي يؤمن بانه يستطيع
تحقيقها
بعد ابتكاره صواريخ فضاء وسيارات كهربائيه
وبطاريات شمسيه ورجالا اليين
وضعه نجاحه في قائمه اكثر الرواد الاعمال
تاثيرا في القرن الحادي والعشرين مع ثروه
تقدر باربعه وتسعين مليار و900 مليون
دولار
هذه قصه شخص يحلم بالفضاء ويساهم ببناء
المستقبل
هذه قصه شخص وضع احلام البشريه قبل احلامه
وكان يامل بتغيير العالم ونجح بذلك
هنالك احتمال كبير لا يمكن التقليل من
خطورته بان شيئا ما سيحدث للارض بالرغم من
نياتنا الحسنه وبالرغم من كل ما نحاول
فعله هنالك احتمال بانه خلال مرحله ما اما
قوه الخارجيه واما خطا داخلي غير مقصود
سيقوم بتدمير الحضاره البشريه
هنالك دائما درجه من التوتر عندما تشاهد
اطلاق اي صاروخ وامروا بان تجري الامور في
شكل سلس ولكن يجب القول اننا اجرينا
الاختبارات وتاكدنا من اعلى درجه ممكنه من
الامان
بدا العد التنازلي عشره تسعه ثمانيه سبعه
خمسه اربعه ثلاثه اثنان واحد صفر
ها قد انطلق صاروخ فالكون 9 الخاص بشركه
سبيس اكس بينما تتجهنا سنحو القطاع الخاص
لاعاده امداد محطه الفضاء الدوليه
البدء بتغير الجاذبيه
المرحله الاولى من التشغيل الكامل للطاقه
تبدو جيده
[موسيقى]
لدينا رابط عن بعد للقياس الشمسي
المرحله الاولى من عمليه تشغيل محركات
الدفع فاعله
المركبه على ارتفاع نسمي ضمن خط السير هو
خمسه كيلو مترات فاصله ثلاثه السرعه هي
225 مترا بالثانيه
وسرعه خفض الارتفاع هي سته اجزاء بالعشره
من الكيلومتر الواحد
سرعه المركبه تتجاوز سرعه الصوت
نحن مقبلون على حقبه جديده من استكشاف
الفضاء وذلك امر مشوق للغايه وهناك شركات
اخرى عده غير سبيس اكس قامت بتطوير نهج
جديد وناسه تقوم بمقاربه الامور باساليب
جديده وذلك امر مشوق حقا
في النهايه التاريخ يرينا ان حدثا جديدا
سيقع
البديل هو ان نصبح حضاره مستعمره للفضاء
ونوعا حيا متعدد الكواكب واتمنى ان تكونوا
متفقين معي على ذلك
[موسيقى]
بدايه بعض الناس لا يدركون ان لدينا محطه
فضائيه حيث يتفاجئون بهذا
لدينا محطه فضائيه هائله انها ضخمه ضخمه
حقا
انه هيكل مذهل حقا يدور حول الارض
واعتقد ان علينا فعل شيء لتثقيف الناس في
شان روعه محطه الفضاء لانها مذهله حقا
الشيء الذي حدث في الاعوام الاخيره
والذي انا متحمس حقا في شانه
واعتقد انه سيحدث فارقا في السفر عبر
الفضاء هو عمليات هبوط معزز
لصاروخ فالكو 9 ثم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولد ايلون ريف ماسك في 28 من يونيو في
العام
1971 في مدينه بريتوريا جنوب افريقيا
كان والده مهندسا جنوب افريقيا ناجحا
وثريا اما والدته ميماسك فكانت عارضه
ازياء كنديه كان ايلون الاكبر من بين
ثلاثه اطفال وامضى طفولته مع شقيقه كيمبال
وشقيقته توسكا في جنوب افريقيا
كان يمكن ان تكون عائلتهم جميله سعيده فقد
بدا كل شيء رائعا من الخارج لكن الواقع
كان مختلفا تماما
[موسيقى]
نشا ايلون في اسره مضطربه وعان طفوله صعبه
ووحيده كان والده يعنف والدته ولم يقدم
لايلون اي مساعده لبدء عمل خاص به لم يكن
مهتما بسعاده اولاده او نجاحهم تطلق والده
ايلون عندما كان في العاشره من عمره
كان ايلان مختلفا
منذ ان كان في الثالثه من عمره ظهرت عليه
دلائل العبقريه وكانت والدته تصفه بالمهوس
بالدراسه ففي سيرتها الذاتيه التي صدرت في
العام 2019 بعنوان امراه تضع خطه شاركت
عددا من الصور المتواضعه لطفولته وكتبت
عندما كان ايلون صغيرا لاحظت انه كان يقرا
كل ما يقع بين يديه ادركت ارن بمقدوره
اداء مهام معقده في سن مبكره جدا وان لديه
ملكه خاصه كان يتعرض للتنمر في المدرسه
عند محاولته الاندماج في الحياه
الاجتماعيه على خلاف اخيه كان قصير القامه
وانطوائيا ومحبا للقراءه ما جعله لا يحظى
بشعبيه كبيره بين اقرانه في تلك المرحله
لم تكن لديه خطه ليصبح مليارديرا
كان دائما الغرق في احلام يقظه حول
ابتكارات مختلفه الى درجه ان والديه
اخضعاه لاختبار التاكد من قدرته على السمع
وسرعان ما نام لديه اهتمام بالكمبيوترات
والاجهزه الالكترونيه
واخيرا بعد ان حصل على اول كمبيوتر له
تعلم البرمجه عندما كان لا يزال في
العاشره من عمره فقط علم نفسه البرمجه بعد
ان ادرك ان الحصص الدراسيه لا تفيده لانه
كان متقدما على معلميه
سرعان ما ادرك ايلون ماسك انه ان تمكن من
كتابه وبيع برمجيات افضل ففي امكانه شراء
كمبيوترات افضل
وهذا ما فعله
لذا ابتكر لعبته الكمبيوتريه الاولى اسمها
بلاستر ثم باعها لاحدى المجلات مقابل 500
دولار
في سن الثانيه عشره دعا اول برنامج تجاري
له
بدا ان ايلون ماسك ولد مع قدره خارقه على
الابتكار بدا بالتفكير كرائد اعمال منذ سن
باكره جدا وولد ليبتكر ويخترع كانت طفولته
صعبه ولكنها منحته ميزه مهمه لتحقيق نجاح
مذهل في وقت لاحق في حياته وهي القدره على
التكيف والتغلب على اصعب التحديات والظروف
[موسيقى]
في يونيو من العام
1989 بدات المرحله الثانيه من حياته حيث
قرر في سن 17 ان يغادر جنوب افريقيا كان
يفكر في الحلم الامريكي تذكر ايلون تفكيره
في ان امريكا هي المكان الذي يمكن فيه
تحقيق انجازات عظيمه اكثر من اي بلد اخر
في العالم
كانت امريكا بالنسبه الى
بلاد الفرص
لم تكن لديه خطه محكمه ولكنه علم ان
البقاء في بلده الام لن يساعده على بلوغ
طموحه بما انه نشا خلال فتره نظام الفصل
العنصري علم ان عليه اتخاذ قرار حاسم فقد
كان يريد تجنب الخدمه العسكريه الاجباريه
ضمن جيش جنوب افريقيا باي ثمن وصف النظام
الفصل العنصري بانه لا يصدق ولم يكن يدعم
او يثق في الحكومه لذا فقد كان الانضمام
الى الخدمه العسكريه الاجباريه امرا غير
وارد
ارتدا ايلون جامعه بريتوريا لخمسه اشهر
قبل ان يخبر والديه برغبته في السفر الى
كندا
قرر مخالفا باراده والده السفر من بلده
الام الى امريكا الشماليه
عمل في وظائف غريبه في كل انحاء البلاد
قبل ان يستقر في جامعه كوينز في مقاطعه
اونتاريو في كندا حيث التقى بزوجته الاولى
جاستين ويلسون تزوج في العام الفين وانجب
خمسه اطفال
ثم انتقل الى الولايات المتحده ليرتداد
جامعه بنسلفانيا في مدينه فيلادلفيا حيث
تخرج بدرجه البكالوريوس في الاقتصاد
والفيزياء في العام 1997
حصل على منحه دراسيه لارتياد جامعه
ستانفورد حيث نال شهاده الدكتوراه في
فيزياء الطاقه
ولكنه لم يكتفي
بما انها كانت فتره نشاه الانترنت اراد
ماسك العمل على تكنولوجيا جديده وقرر
الانتقال الى منطقه سيليكون فالي في ولايه
كاليفورنيا وهي ارض الميعاد لاي رائد
اعمال في مجال التكنولوجيا
وذلك اكثر مكان اعتقد ان في امكانه تحقيق
النجاح فيه
ولكنه عان لايجاد وظيفه هناك بسبب احتدام
المنافسه وقله عدد الوظائف المتاحه
ولكن ذلك لم يثبط من عزيمته فقد قرر انه
سيبتكر عملا خاصا به
سرعان ما تبين ان ماسك كان يجيد توقع
المشكلات المستقبليه التي سيعاني منها
العالم
كما انه سيتمكن من ابتكار حل
عندما انتقل الى
كان هدفه هو التاثير على مستقبل الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
كان حينها الانترنت ما يزال عمره سنتين
فحسب لذا فقد فكر في ان ذلك كان المكان
الذي يمكنه احداث تاثير فيه
لم تكن معظم الاعمال المحليه تمتلك مواقع
على الانترنت حينها كانت موجوده ضمن كتب
الادله التجاريه فحسب فكر ماسك بانه
سيخترع شيئا ليساعد الجرائد ووسائل
الاعلام المطبوع على الانتقال الى
الانترنت وخلق وجود الكتروني لها لم يؤمن
الناس بفكره فما الذي يمكنه استبدال
الادله التجاريه ولكنه كان حينها يمتلك
المعرفه والخبره اللازمتين لكتابه برامج
للانترنت
علم انه اراد جعل اشياء مفيده تحدث على
الانترنت بالرغم من انه لم يملك ادنى فكره
عما سيصنع في البدايه
تغير ذلك بسرعه فقد ابتكر اول برامج
الانترنت الخاصه به والذي كان يسمح لوسائط
الاعلام ان تحول مطبوعاتها الورقيه الى
محتوى رقمي كان هذا اساس شركته الاولى
المسماه زبتو والتي اسسها مع شقيقه كمبال
في عام
1995 لم تكن لديه فكره عن مدى الصعوبات
التي سيواجهها في السنوات الاولى بعد
انتقاله من جنوب افريقيا وترتب ديون
دراسيه ضخمه عليه كان ماسك فقيرا الى درجه
انه لم يستطع تحمل اكله في منزله ومكتب
لشركته انتهى به المطاف بان يضطر الى
النوم على اريكه في مكتبه الصغير
والاستحمام في نادي رياضيا محلي كانت
الحماسه تعم الشهور القليله الاولى لكن
بعد اشهر عده بدا الامر يصبح صعبا حقا فقد
اصطدم بالواقع الصعب فالاشياء لا تجري وفق
المخططات دائما ولم تكن الامور تسير في
شكل جيد كما ظن انها ستفعل في نهايه
المطاف نمط شركته وحققت النجاح وعقد صفقات
مع زبائن اكبر واكبر مثل نيويورك تايمز
بعد اربع سنين تمكن من تحقيق النجاح الذي
اراداه منذ البدايه
في فبراير من العام
1999 اشترت شركه التكنولوجيا كومباك شركه
زيب 2 مقابله 307 ملايين دولار نقدا
واربعه وثلاثين مليون دولار على شكل اسهم
كان ماسك لا يزال في سن الثامنه والعشرين
عندما انضم الى قائمه مليونيرات سيليكون
فالي تغيرت حاله من رجل مفلس ينام على
اريكه مكتبه الى مليونير بين عشيه وضحاها
ولكن ماذا كان سيفعل بكل تلك الاموال
الجديده سيشتري لعبه جديده ذهب واشترى
احدى اعلى السيارات اداء يمكن ان يشتريها
المال في تلك الفتره وهي ماكلارين
بسعر مليون دولار
كان ذلك التصرف رخيصا
ولكن ماسكا اراد اكثر من مجرد اشياء ماديه
لقد اراد تغيير العالم ولم يكن يسعى الى
مجرد تغيير صغير في تاريخ الجرائد فحسب لم
يكن لشركه التاثير المهم الذي كان يتطلع
اليه وبدا بسرعه يفكر ببناء شركه جديده
كان دائما يفكر فيما يمكنهما فعله لاحقا
ماذا عن تطوير القطع المصرفي
بعد بيع شركته
زادت ثقته بنفسه وبات مستعدا لتحد جديد
لم يكن لطموحه حدود
في العام
1999 بعد شهر فقط من بيع شركه زبتو استخدم
ايلون
الشركه الغنيه عن التعريف كانت التحويلات
الماليه تسير ببطء شديد في الواقع كان
ارسال الناس الشيكات المصرفيه بريديا الى
بعضهم بعضا يعني ان اكمال عمليات مصرفيه
واحده يستغرق اسابيع كامله لحظه ماسك ان
هنالك مشكله تحتاج الى حل وفرصه لاحداث
تغيير مهم في القطاع المالي اسس شركه
بايبال لتسهيل عمليه الدفع والتحويلات
الماليه من دون الاضطرار الى التعامل نقدا
في البدايه كانت الشركه صغيره ومجهوله لكن
ماسك كان سابقا لعصره كان الظروف مشروعه
الثاني افضل من الاول نمى المشروع بسرعه
وفي حلول نهايه العام الثاني بلغ عدد
المستخدمين نحو مليون شخص
في اكتوبر من العام 2002 اي بعد سنه ونصف
من اطلاق الشركه تم طرده من منصبه كمدير
تنفيذي لشركته الخاصه والسبب وراء ذلك كان
انه قرر الذهب في اجازه خلال فتره صعبه
بالنسبه الى باي بال حيث كانت تعاني من
الكثير من المشكلات عندما عاد اكتشف ان
منصبه كمدير تنفيذيا قد تم سحبه منه قرر
فريقه انه لم يعد الشخص المناسب لاداره
هذه الشركه ولكن الاشياء كانت توشك على
التحسن مره اخرى في عام 2002 اشترت شركه
ايباي باي مقابل مليار ونصف المليار دولار
حصل حينها على 150 مليون دولار لكونه صاحب
اكبر كم من الاسهم وقد ادى هذا الوضع الى
اصلاح علاقته مع فريقه وتحسنت بذلك
علاقاته ضمن مجال الاعمال ولكن لم يكن كل
شيء يجري في شكل جيد في ذلك العام تاثر
وزوجته بماساه
بعد بيعه شركه باي بال انتقل ماسك مع
زوجته جاستين الى لوس انجلوس وولد لهما
اول طفل صبي اسمه نيفادا اليكساندر
في الاسبوع نفسه الذي تضاعفت فيه ثروه
ايلون لتصل الى 100 مليون دولار توقف
طفلهما عن التنفس فجاه
توفي بسبب متلازمه الموت المفاجئ عند
الرضع كان يبلغ عشره اسابيع فقط
جنى ايلون اول مليار دولار له ولكنه فقد
طفلا
رفض بعضها التحدث عن موت نيفادا وقرر مع
زوجته انجاب اطفال اخرين في اقرب وقت ممكن
خلال الاغوام الخمسه التاليه وبمساعده
تقنيه التلقيح الصناعي انجبت جاستين تواما
ثنائيا ثم توائم ثلاثيه خمسه ابناء في
المجمل
عاش هو وعائلته حلما او ذلك ما بدا عليه
الامر حيث صرح جاستين انها تشعر بانها
مجرد زوجه رجل
مهمشه وان علاقتهما اصبحت غير صحيه وغير
قابله للاستمرار ادى موت طفلهما الاول
الماساوي واولويات ايلون وهوسه بعمله الى
تباعدهما وفي النهايه الى طلاقهما في
العام 2008 والذي كان عاما مملوءا
بالتحديات
بعد فتره ليست بطويله في العام 2010 قابل
زوجته الثانيه الممثله البريطانيه تالولا
رايلي تقدم للزواج منها بعد عشره ايام فقط
من تواعدهما تطلقا ثم تزوج مجددا في العام
2013 ثم انتهز وجوهما مجددا في العام 2016
رغم المشكلات والعقبات تمكن ماسك اخيرا من
بلوغ قوه التاثير التي طمح اليها
ابتكرت شركته شيئا بتنا نعتبره من
المسلمات لكنه غير طريقه تحويل الاموال
وشراءنا الاشياء لم يكن من الممكن انكار
الانجازات التي حققها ماسك خلال ثلاث
سنوات فقط
في العام 2002 عندما كان في سن الحاديه
والثلاثين اصبح ماسك مواطنا امريكيا
ومليارديرا في هذه المرحله كان في امكانه
التقاعد بسهوله وشراء جزر استوائيه وتناول
الاطعمه الشهيه الى بقيه عمره لكن ذلك لم
يكن يستحوذ على اهتمامه اهتم ماسك بمستقبل
اكثر الهاما مثل استكشاف الفضاء الخارجي
لم يكن المستقبل الذي يشعره بالالهام هو
مستقبل يبقى فيه البشر محاصرين ضمن الارض
بعد نجاح باي بال اصبح جاهزا لاتخاذ
الخطوات التاليه ضمن مجال استكشاف الفضاء
الخارجي هدفه الجديد هو تمكين الحضاره
البشريه من ان تغادر كوكب الارض من طفل لا
يمتلك رؤيه كبيره او واضحه في البدايه الى
رائد اعمال عبقري ذي رؤيه اعظم من ان يمكن
ان يتخيله معظم الناس
اصبحت اهداف ماسك الطموحه اكثر تتحول الى
اولويه اكبر بالنسبه اليه
[موسيقى]
كان المريخ محطه عينيه
في العام 2002 اسس شركته الثالثه سبيس اكس
شركه تقنيات استكشاف الفضاء معنيه صنع
مركبه فضائيه للسفر الفضائي التجاري تم
تاسيس الشركه بعد ان ادرك مدى ارتفاع كلفه
شراء صواريخ من السوق وبعد ان توصل الى
خلاصه مفادها ان سبب عدم تحقيق تقدم كبير
في مجال استكشاف الفضاء كان ان الصواريخ
لم تتطور منذ الستينيات
هدفه هو صنع صواريخ رخيصه وبيعها الى
الشركات الخاصه والحكومه
كان ماسك يعتقد ان الحل لجعل السفر عبر
الفضاء ذا كلفه مقبوله هو صنع صواريخ
قابله لاعاده الاستخدام رغم اعتقاد خبراء
الفضاء بانه يستحيل صنع صواريخ قابله
لاعاده الاستخدام
تاسست شركه سبيس اكس في العام 2008
وقد منحت ناس سبيس اكس عقدا لامداد محطه
الفضاء الدوليه بالمعدات
كانت الخطه استبدال مهمات النقل الفضائيه
الخاصه بناسا نفسها ما تريد وكاله الفضاء
الدوليه فعله هو القيام تدريجيا بتسليم
اداره محطه الفضاء الدوليه كامله الى
الشركات التجاريه
رحله الفضاء البشريه هذه هي سبب تاسيس
شركه سبيس اكس وانه لشرف عظيم لنا ان
نشترك مع ناسا
لتحقيق هذا نريدك وكاله ان نذهب الى
المريخ وما بعده وبالطبع نحن متحمسون جدا
حيال ما يجلبه ايلون من حماسه الى هذا
المجال وفكره سبيس اكس في السفر بالبشر
عبر انحاء النظام الشمسي
دخل ماسك التاريخ في مايو من العام 2012
بعد عمليه اقلاع لصاروخ فالكون 9 الذي
انطلق نحو الفضاء من دون ان يحمل على متنه
احدا تم ارسال المركبه التجاريه الاولى
نحو محطه الفضاء الدوليه
كما اصبحت سبيس اكس الشركه الخاصه الاولى
التي تنجح في اطلاق مركبه فضائيه والعوده
بها من مدار الارض
نطمح الى ان يصبح الوجود على سطح كوكب اخر
امرا ممكنا مثل قاعده على القمر او ما
شابه ومن ثم الانطلاق الى المريخ وما بعد
ذلك ومتابعه حلم مشروع ابولو الذي يتطلع
الناس اليه
في العام 2015 بدات سبيس اكس بتطوير مشروع
ستارلينج لتامين وصول الى الانترنت عبر
الاقمار الاصطناعيه وفي الرابع والعشرين
من مايو في العام 2019 تم اطلاق اول 60
قمرا اصطناعيا عاملا يكلف المشروع نحو
عشره مليارات دولار
هذه خطوه مهمه جدا بالنسبه الينا كما انها
خطوه كبيره بالنسبه الى المشاريع التجاريه
واعتقد انه من المهم ان يدرك العالم اننا
ذاهبون الى الفضاء بهدف البقاء فيه وسوف
نكمل بعدها الى القمر ثم الى المريخ
لتكنولوجيا تصديعي بالموائع اخطار كبيره
وراى انها ما تزال في مرحله مبكره لانني
اعتقد ان التصديع بالمائع يزيد كميه النفط
والغاز التي يمكن الوصول اليها في العالم
بنسبه حوالي عشره اضعاف
ولا نعلم مدى ضررها في شكل كامل وعلى
الارجح يتسارع اثر ضررها في شكل ماساوي
مما يعني ان الضرر على المناخ يشد بكثيرا
مما كان عليه سابقا ولا يمكننا الاعتماد
على قله الموارد لرفع اسعار النفط والغاز
والاعتماد على ذلك لدفعنا نحو الاعتماد
على الطاقه الكهربائيه
لذا علينا معرفه كيفيه جعل السيارات
الكهربائيه فكره جذابه من دون الاعتماد
على الدافع الاقتصادي
لاسعار الوقود المرتفعه
في التسعينات كان السبب الرئيسي الانتقال
ماسك الى سيليكون فالي في المقام الاول هو
العمل على السيارات الكهربائيه
حيث قرر في ذلك الوقت انه كان من الافضل
ان يصبح جزءا من الانترنت الذي كان اخذا
في النمو ولكن حلمه في صنع سيارات
كهربائيه بقي في ذهنه طوال هذه السنوات
كان يحتاج الى كل الحظ الممكن له ان يحصل
عليه بعد نقلته عام 2004
نظرا الى انه لطالما سحرته الصواريخ
والسيارات السريعه اراد ماسك ايجاد طريقه
للتخفيف من الاحتباس الحراري وانهاء
الاستخدام المدمر للوقود الاحفوري
كان العام 2004 العام الذي بدا فيه
الاستثمار في شركه اعتقد انها ستغير
مستقبل الانسانيه وتبني مستقبلا اكثر
استدامه
شركه صاحبه تكنولوجيا ثوريه تعتمد على
حمايه البيئه وتقديم افضل تجربه ممكنه
للزبون ليحقق النجاح
وهي الشركه الغنيه عن التعريف تسلا موتورز
كانت خطه تسلا انتاج سياره مرغوب فيها لدى
الجميع واقتصاديه بالاضافه الى صناعه
البطاريه الا ان ماسك لم يؤسس هذه الشركه
وانما اسسها مهندسان اقل شهره كانت لديهما
رؤيه لابتكار وسائط نقل تعمل بطاقه افضل
للبيئه في شهر ابريل من العام 2004
سعادهما على اطلاق شركه تسلا بواسطه سته
ملايين ونصف مليون دولار من ماله الخاص
وعين رئيسا للشركه في العام 2006 عندما
كان يبلغ 32 عاما وفي سياق جهوده
المتواصله لتطوير طاقه متجدده ساعد قريبيه
لندن وبتاسيس شركه وهي شركه تطور وتبيع
الواح شمسيه واسقفا شمسيه اصبحت سول سيتي
اكبر مزود لخدمات الطاقه الشمسيه في
الولايات المتحده في العام 2008 اطلقت
تسلا سياره رودستر الاولى وهي سياره
رياضيه قاد على الانطلاق من سرعه صفر الى
97 كيلومترا في الساعه خلال ثلاث فاصله
سبعه من الثانيه لكن ماسك قلل من شان كلفه
انتاج مثل تلك السيارات الفاخره بحلول
العام 2007 بدات الشركه تتجه نحو الافلاس
هدفنا صنع سيارات معقوله السعر في اقرب
وقت لكن على اي تكنولوجيا جديده المرور في
مرحله تطوير والخضوع لدراسات اقتصاديه وما
شابه لذا بالنسبه الى كوننا شركه صغيره
ناشئه كان علينا انتاج سيارات بكميه انتاج
منخفضه وذات كلفه باهظه ولم تمتلك الا
النسخه الاولى من التكنولوجيا لم تبع
الشركه تسلا سوى 1300 سياره روتستر لذا
يرى النقاد ان شركه صغيره كهذه لن تتمكن
ابدا من النمو في شكل كاف لاحداث ثوره في
قطاع السيارات لكنها باعت تكنولوجيا
بطاريتها الى شركه دملر التي ستصنع
بواسطتها السياره كهربائيه ذكيه وياملون
ان نسخه عاديه من سياره رودستر ستتمتع
بقدره كافيه لاقناع العامه بان المستقبل
يكم في الطاقه الكهربائيه اعتقد ان كل
وسائط النقل باستثناء الصواريخ ستصبح
معتمده كليا على الطاقه الكهربائيه
وارى ان قيمه شركه تسلا تكمن في كونها
وسيطا يسرع من عمليه الانتقال هذه لم
يتمكنوا من التنبؤ بمدى صعوبه السنوات
التاليه زعزعه ازمه عام 2008 الاقتصاديه
العالميه الاقتصاد باكمله ادرك ماسك انه
كان يواجه اسوا ازمه في حياته المهنيه
كلها وبدا ان شركاته الثلاث كلها تواجه
ضائقه ماليه شديده لم يكن لسياره كهربائيه
الاخرى ففي اوقات كاتيلك كان من المؤكد ان
الناس لن يقوموا بانفاق 100 الف دولار على
سياره رياضيه قبل عيد الميلاد من العام
2008 كانت شركه تسلا على بعد يومين من
الافلاس كانت لدى كل من تسلا وسبيس اكس
فرصه عشره في المئه تقريبا للنجاه انسحب
المصرف الممول لعقود ايجاراتهم العقاريه
من الصفقه
كان ماسك في كفاح من اجل حياته
كان هذا العام عام نهايه زواجه من جاستين
ايضا
كانت تسلا توشك على الافلاس لكن ماسك انقذ
الشركه بعمل بطولي في احلى ساعاتها
استثمر كل ما تبقى لديه من صفقه باي بال
في شركه تسلا وهو مشروع ما يزال يؤمن فيه
بقوه
ولكن كانت ثقته بنفسه تلك هي سبب ثقه
الناس به لقد كان واثقا بافكاره ولذلك
اراد المستثمرون جزءا من تلك الافكار ايضا
وقد نجح في ذلك
في العام 2010 طرح اسهم الشركه للتداول
العام ولكن لم يكن الجميع متفائلا في شان
مستقبل الشركه وفي الواقع صوتت على كونها
الشركه الاقل احتمالا للنجاح ولكن
المستثمرين تجاهل المشككين
سبب القيام بذلك وقيام العديد من الناس في
شركه تسلا بذلك هو اننا نعتقد ان الانتقال
الى وسائط نقل تعتمد على طاقه متجدده في
اقرب وقت ممكن سيحدث فارقا في العالم وليس
لنصبح اثرياء او ما شابه فكما قلت شعرت ان
احتمال نجاحك عشره في المئه في البدايه
وظننت انني قد اخسر كل مالي وهذا ما كاد
يحدث بالفعل جئت اخسر كل شيء
في العام 2013 كانت الظروف اعماله في
ازدهار اصبحت الضائقه الماليه امرا من
الماضي
[موسيقى]
وخرج بمزيد من الابتكارات
في اغسطس من العام 2013 اطلق ماسك فكره
لنوع جديد من وسائل النقل يسمى هايبر لوب
وهو اختراع يسمح بالسفر بين المدن الكبرى
خلال وقت قصير جدا مما يخفف الازدحام
المروريه في شكل كبير
حيث كانت مقاومه للظروف الجويه في شكل
مثالي وتستمد طاقتها من مصادر متجدده كان
سيتم اطلاق ركاب هايبر لوب ضمن كبسولات
عبر انابيب بسرعه تصل الى اكثر من 1226
كيلومترا في الساعه بالرغم من ان ماسك قدم
فكره هايبر لوب قائلا انها ستكون اكثر
امانا من السفر بالطائره وبكلفه سته
مليارات تقديريا الا ان الناس شككوا
بفكرته الجديده ولكن ماسك ما يزال يشجع
على تطوير هذه الفكره لم يتوقف ايلون ماسك
عند هذا الحد فالمستقبل يعني وجوب التعامل
مع الذكاء الاصطناعي ايضا لذا اهتم بالعمل
كشريك لرئيس شركه اوبن اي اي غير الربحيه
اطلقت الشركه البحثيه في اواخر العام 2015
بهدف تطوير مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي لافاده
البشريه
كما شارك في تاسيس شركه نيورلنك في العام
2016 وهي شركه الناشئه تركز على دمج
الدماغ البشري بالذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان
تحسن هذه الابتكارات الذاكره او تساعد
البشر على الاندماج مع البرامج
الكمبيوتريه كشف ان تلك الاجهزه ستتكون من
شريحه مصغره تتصل بهاتف ذكي عبر تقنيه
البلوتوث في اغسطس من العام 2016 وضمن جهد
ماسك المستمره للترويج لطاقه ولمنتجات
مستدامه ومتطوره قامت شركه تسلا بشراء
سولار سيتي لقد اثبت مكانته كقائد لهذا
القطاع الصناعي
تستطيع سيارتنا طويله المدى قطع مسافه 600
كيلومتر كما اننا نقوم بتطوير سيارات على
المدى البعيد يمكنها قطع 1000 كم احد
الاجزاء الاكثر صعوبه هو القيام بعدها
برفع مستوى الانتاج وتحقيق درجات عاليه
جدا من الوثوقيه والامان يجب ان تتم
الاشياء على نطاق كبير جدا لذا هذا يعني
انه مصنع كبير جدا وهنالك الكثير من
المصممين الموهوبين والمهندسين في اوروبا
بكل تاكيد واعتقد ان الكثير من امهر الناس
سيودون العمل في مكان يقومون فيه بانتاج
تصاميم اصليه ومبتكره سيكون من المنطقي
انتاج سياره صغيره الحجم في اوروبا مثل
سيارات
وهذا سيساعدنا ايضا على ان نقول حسنا
نحتاج الى سياره يمكن الناس تحمل كلفتها
كما انها تناسب اسلوب حياتهم
[موسيقى]
اتوقع انه خلال نحو عشره اعوام على الارجح
سيصبح من المعتاد صنع سيارات ذاتيه
القياده في شكل كامل سيصبح امتلاكه سياره
غير ذاتيه القياده في المستقبل
مثل امتلاك حصان
حيث قد تمتلك واحدا وتستخدمه لاسباب
ترفيهيه لكن ليس للاستخدام اليومي
كما اعلن ان من اهدافه الرئيسيه الوصول
بالبشر الى المريخ الا انه كذلك منذ عام
2001 انه هدف رائع له تاريخ محدد لتحقيقه
العام 2024 ان مستقبلا نكون فيه حضاره
مستعمره للفضاء والنجوم اكثر تشويقا
بتاكيد من مستقبل لا نكون فيه كذلك اعتقد
ان من لا يعجبه ذلك المستقبل يكره البشريه
بالتاكيد
بعد الوصول بالبشر الى الهبوط على سطح
القمر يامل ان يجعل السفر عبر الفضاء
معقول الكلفه وان يقوم مبلغ 100 الف دولار
للشخص الواحد باغراء البشر بالانتقال الى
المريخ في شكل دائم التزامه وحلمه بجعل
الحياه على كواكب متعدده ممكنا يلخص اي
نوع من الرجال قد اصبح او ربما ما كان
عليه طوال الوقت في العام 2018 كان ايلون
ماسك ما يزال مستمرا في ابتكار افكار
جديده ومثيره للاهتمام للمستقبل اعلن عن
سفر اول رائد فضاء خاص الى القمر وهو
يوساكو مايوزاوا
اود تقديم اول زبون خاص لصواريخنا
يوساكو ما يوزاوا تفضل رجاء
اجل
[تصفيق]
شكرا لكم جميعا
في العام 2023
وبصفه المضيف اود دعوه سته الى ثمانيه
فنانين من مختلف انحاء العالم للانضمام
الي في هذه الرحله نحو القمر
هذه المهمه الى القمر هي دليل جديد على ان
ماسك لن يتوقف عند اي حد حتى يتمكن من
ايصال العالم الى الفضاء
اعتقد ان خطط الى الماسك مذهله واعني ذلك
بطريقتين فهي مذهله كما انها من دروب
الخيال
فافكاره تقودنا الى الامام بطريقه ما كما
انه صاحب بصيره نافذه ولكنها ايضا خياليه
لانها غالبا ستحتاج الى وقت اطول بكثير
مما يعتقده
[موسيقى]
فيما يؤمن العام 2018
ظهر ماسك في حفل ماتجال مع صديقته الجديده
المغنيه الكنديه كلير بوشير
[موسيقى]
المعروفه بالاسم الفني جراينز تعارف عبر
الانترنت قبل اسابيع عده بعدما اكتشف ماسك
مزحه على تويتر بشان الذكاء الاصطناعي على
حساب جرامز تواصل معها وبدا يتواعدان
بعيدا عن الانظار منذ ذلك الحين
قال ماسك لمجله
انه يحبها لابداعها الفني الجامح وحبها
للعمل الجاد بعد عامين في مايو من العام
2020 اعلن ايلون ماسك مولد طفلهما الاول
على تويتر ابن يحمل اسما غير اعتياديا
قام باختصاره الى اكس
اعلنا انهما اطلق على طفلهما الجديد اسمه
ماسك
الاسم مكون من حرف اكس
ثم حرفي
يلفظان اش
اجل ثم
والتي هي مساهمتي لماذا
سلف طائره
اروع طائره على الاطلاق
احب كيف ضحك روكا بسبب استغرابنا من اين
اتيت بكلمه اش من ذلك الاسم
لكن انظروا الى متى ترافت الطفل
تعرض لاسم على ما يبدو لبعض المشكلات
الاداريه وهذا هو السبب بسبب الجدال حول
وجود نص في قانونك الفورنيا يفيد بان اسم
الطفل يجب ان يحتوي على احرف من الابجديه
الانجليزيه فقط قام ايلون ماسك وجريمز
بتغيير الارقام في الاسم واستبدالها باحرف
اما كنيه الطفل فهي ببساطه لم يكن اسم طفل
ماسك الشيء الجدلي الوحيد في شانه انه
معروف بكونه مثيرا للجدال اعلى تويتر في
مايو من العام 2020 افقد شركه تسلا 14
مليار دولار من قيمتها بواسطه تغريده
واحده حيث كتب سعر سهم شركه تسلا مرتفع
اكثر من اللازم
خسر ثلاثه مليارات دولار من ثروته الخاصه
نتيجه انسحاب مستثمرين نتيجه تغريدته كما
اعلن ماسك ان تغريداته على تويتر مجنونه
دائما
بعض زواجه ثلاث مرات مرتين من المرات
نفسها وانجاب سته اطفال وتسببه في خساره
ملك الاسهم في شركات مليارات الدولارات
بتغريداته من العدل القول ان حياته
الشخصيه مضطربه بقدر حياته المهنيه
لم تكن رحلته مكونه دائما من نجاحات
واوقات سعيده لكن ايلون ماسك تمكن في
النهايه من بلوغ النجاح الذي طماح اليه لم
يتمكن شيء من ايقافه
من الرائع خروجه بهذه الفكره فالامر ملهم
ومثير للدهشه ولكن اعتقد ان انجاز هذا
خلال عشر سنوات سيشكل تحديا كبيرا امل ان
نقوم بامر كهذا ولكن من المرجح اننا سنرسل
مهمه اصغر اولا لنعرف ان كان في امكان
الناس العيش على سطح المريخ فعلا قبل ان
نرسل مئه شخص الى هناك اعتقد انه من الصعب
عليه ايجاد طريقه لتمويل الامر
لهناك حدود للمدى الذي قد تغير فيه
مخيلتكم الواقع
لا يعتقد ايلون ماسك ذلك
لقد ضرب للعالم مثالا على ان النجاح يستحق
المعاناه
تحول من شخص غير معروف الى مبرمج ثم الى
مهندس ثم الى مليونير عبقري وعصامي ثم الى
مدير تنفيذي ملتزم ومغامر متعدد المهمات
وملياردير
تسببت ابتكارات ماسك الثوريه وافكاره
المبتكره باثاره الكثير من الشكوك خاصه من
ناحيه التمويل
افكاره محطه اعجاب للكثيرين الا ان البعض
يشككون في امكان تحقيقها
يراه بعض الناس رجل اعمال مجنونا بافكار
اكبر منه شخصيا
ولكن المستثمرين يثقون بجنونه الابتكاري
[موسيقى]
لا يمكننا ان ننكر ان ايلون ماسك شخص ذكي
جدا ومبتكر عبقري
رؤيته للمستقبل ملهمه وطموحه
[موسيقى]
ماسك رجل ذو بصيره نافذه في مجتمعنا
المعاصر والمتحول ارانا جميعا كيفيه فعل
اشياء جديده لم نعتقد انه يمكن القيام بها
من قبل اطلقت عليه مجله تايم لقب احد اكثر
الاشخاص تاثيرا في العالم
لطالما تحلى بالثقه والتفاؤل واصل الكفاح
في اصعب الايام ولم يستسلم اطلاقا
جميعها امثله على ان التزامه بالزبائن قد
اثمر حسنا وكان لجميعها اثر مهم على
العالم وساهمت جميعها في تحقيق التقدم
بطريقه ذكيه
اصبحت مهمته الوحيده هي ضمان مستقبل
البشريه
ايلون ماسك مثال على ذلك اعتقد ان الفضاء
هو من الاشياء التي تلهم معظم الناس وان
سالت الناس عن الحدث الاكثر الهاما في
التاريخ فعل الارجح ان يجيب بانه الهبوط
على سطح القمر اعتقد ان هذا سيكون جوابهم
في شتى انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
تعلمنا منه ان كل شيء يبدا بشخص واحد
باحلامه وطموحاته كل شيء يبدا بشخص يريد
ان يجعل من العالم مكانا افضل
يبدو انه بالنسبه الى ايلون ماسك حتى
السماء ليست حدا لطموحه
[موسيقى]
لا توجد حدود لطموحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات